want to know what's heating up in  theaters this weekend this ancient power  has returned the ultimate adventure and  an ancient horror combined in The Mummy  starring Tom Cruise and Russell Crowe  you saw that right we never go out at  night a man will do anything to protect  his family deep in the woods and it  comes at night can't trust anyone but  family what are you going to do with us  hunter come in my cousin rachel is a  period piece mystery about a man trying  to uncover the truth behind a recent  death okay okay oh wait see what's hot  in theaters with this week's  anticipation so what's your weekend to  get going to be let us know by  commenting see you next time on weekend  take it  [Music]